Quanto mais a mídia fala que diabo é que
eu tô fazendo da minha vida meu Deus a
cara toda riscada paressa uma porta do
banheiro de escola lutei contra um
polonês tô com luta marcada com um
inglês dia 15 agora os confusão que eu
arrumo viu eu era crente daqueles que
qualquer coisinha fala Misericórdia
agora eu sou isso aqui mas eu tô de boas
O importante é que eu tô de boas comendo
minha dietinha de boas fazendo meus
treinos de boas T vez eu apanho mas é de
boas Será que o matu já almoçou Tet e o
Will só anda junto os três meu Deus eu
tô na Irlanda vai que que o nome é rua
sem saída se a gente pode sair pelo
mesmo lugarzinho que entrou se uma gota
de Seme tem mais vida que uma gota de
sangue que que o vampir não Chupa minha
para casa Man tô cansado ente você é
guerreiro aba forte malha muito ninguém
aguentou tanto ferro quanto você muita
proteína ninguém botou tanto ovo na boca
você não já quebrou um pau no cu quebre
outro pau no cu eu acredito em você você
pode quebrar quantos pau no cu você
quiser você pode ser conhecido como
quebrador de pau no cu ela levou Muito
[__] nos treinos aguentou tudo
aguentou firme V os comentários nas
páginas de esporte o povo fica tirando
onda com a minha cara mas é assim mesmo
muitos vão gozar da sua cara e você vai
engolir tudo e vai seguir em frente lá
ele pensar é guaj rapaz vai treinar Bora
Foco